tu as quoi dans ton sac tu es une bombe
j'ai un grand rasoir les vieux rasoirs
jusqu'en terminal je fais une terminale
Bay non j'ai eu que la première partie
française
je rigolais bien et j'avais donc des
amis qui étaient beaucoup plus âgés que
moi et qui michetonnait et donc j'ai
commencé à michetonner vers l'âge de 16
ans comment ça s'est passé la première
fois la première fois c'était un petit
ami d'une de mes amis
qui avait 35 36 ans à peu près elle
avait 20 ans
elle m'a présenté puis on sait plus quoi
mutuellement et puis bon bah
jamais présenté son ami à une copine et
comme ça quoi
le restaurant
qui est très
intéressants
quand même ça consiste en quoi alors
c'est quelqu'un qui qui a un travail
et qui fait ça pour arrondir ses fins de
moi c'est ça la différence qui veut
réussir dans la vie et donc elle
commence par ça et
moi mes ambitions personnelles sont
d'ouvrir une société d'informatique
là je bosse dans l'informatique à
mi-temps je prends des cours de
programmation
[Musique]
très sérieuse très sérieux
d'abord sur Paris
[Musique]
parce que c'est là où on peut trouver
des personnes plus intéressantes on
commence à se passe
à une personne je fais d'abord du
vitrines je regarde donc si les
personnes qui sont donc très très bien
de
vestimentaire tout investimentaire et je
vais demander du feu et puis
généralement ça se passe tout de suite
parce que la personne sent donc ça se
passe
toujours tailleur
je vous offre un pot et puis bon ben je
commence à lui dire oui mais on a du pot
c'est 500 francs pour une fellation et
1000 francs pour la passe plus l'hôtel
voilà alors la fellation se passe
toujours dans la voiture donc la
personne met un préservatif parce
qu'avec le SIDA
on peut avoir des problèmes et dans la
voiture sinon dans l'hôtel on va dans un
hôtel dans un hôtel généralement j'ai
l'habitude d'aller Jean-Paul les trois
quatre ou quand
la fellation ça peut durer 20 minutes à
peu près 20 minutes et puis la passe
c'est une heure
au restaurant c'est après ou avant
après c'est fini après on prend on fait
nos petites toilettes déjà en arrivant
sa petite toilette intime et avant de
repartir maintenant on se nettoie et
puis on se quitte comme ça je m'en vais
j'ai des clients réguliers oui surtout
pour la les massages à domicile
rasoirs
[Musique]
et les massages je me fais à peu près
20000 francs c'est pas mal hein
et dans l'informatique tu gagnes combien
tu as touché 5000 francs
pour leur faire des trucs un peu
spéciaux ou si le mec veut un truc un
peu particulier oui ça m'est déjà arrivé
une personne qui était donc je suis
venue pour le faire à massage et
il m'a demandé il était scato
scatologie bon alors là je vais demander
quand même 500 en plus c'est pas
beaucoup en plus quand même oui c'est
peut-être pas beaucoup mais
faut quand même pas trop demander
qu'il avait déjà payé 500 francs de
massage 500 francs quand même enfin
quand je peux tirer je tire mais bon il
se trouvait que cette personne
pas trop insister
sinon il y a beaucoup d'hommes du très
très connu notamment un qui s'est fait
on a entendu donc parler énormément de
lui passer dernier temps et
de prendre du plaisir avec les mecs
quand la personne me plaît oui beaucoup
parce qu'il plaisait
eu envie mais
je ne ferai jamais parce que c'est
business
de faire ce que je fais que plutôt un
métier quelconque
tes parents ils savent pas ça mes
parents ne le savent pas non
ça risquerait de leur faire beaucoup de
peine
c'est ma vie quoi ça les regarde pas
de petites
je suis jeune j'ai 20 ans j'ai tout le
temps de pensé à l'avenir
côté foyer je veux pas rentrer dans ce
milieu où c'est travail maison de dos
à manger non pas du tout
je pourrais pas dire au moins
je serai pas trop lire à peu près en
gros si c'est quand ça marche très bien
demander à de la famille tu penses quoi
les hommes les hommes
les actions tous les mêmes et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater
vous et mettez un pouce bleu